>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Good morning, everyone,
and thanks for joining the session.
My name is Jorge, and I work with the Chrome
Security team.
Today I'll be talking about how to make Chrome
apps and extensions be more secure.
And as the subtitle of the talk says, we want
to focus on keeping the users of these apps
and extensions safe.
Now, a lot of work has been done, not only
by Google, but by other browser vendors as
well, to make browsers more secure.
What does this mean?
It's harder now for a malicious Web site,
any random Web site to compromise a browser
in a way in which it would allow the attacker
to execute arbitrary code in the user's device.
However, in order to also protect the user's
data, the data that the user keeps in your
Web app or Chrome app or Chrome extension,
we need the help of you, the developers.
The browser by itself cannot completely protect
the user's data from attack.
Now, the good news is that the Web platform
itself has been exposed to untrusted content
or malicious content basically from the start.
That doesn't mean we're always scared about
this malicious content, but we've made a lot
of progress integrating features that allow
developers to make their Web apps more secure.
However, we haven't seen the level of adoption
that we would have liked.
And an objective of the session is to tell
you about these features so that you can use
them and make your applications more secure.
The browser, together with the application
developers, will really make applications
secure.
Now, of course, a 45-minute long talk is not
enough to cover every single aspect of Web
app security, so I'm going to focus on the
client side.
I'm going to try to go over the features that
can be leveraged both by regular Web apps,
by Chrome apps, Chrome extensions, even the
ones that run offline.
Now, I talked about the Web platform and how
we have incorporated features that help developers
make more secure Web apps.
I'm going to focus on two of them which we
believe, the security community at large believe
provide the best bang for the buck.
Number one, content security policy.
If people here attended a talk on Wednesday
about Manifest Version 2 and Extensions Version
2, they probably have heard about CSP.
And they probably also have heard about HTML5
sandboxed iFrames.
I'm going to talk about these two technologies
and show how you use them, common pitfalls
that occur when you use them, so that you
can leave the talk and at least if you leave
the talk and try to use some of these features
in your apps and extensions, I will be very,
very happy indeed.
Now, before going in-depth into the features
I want to take a couple of seconds to go over
the same origin policy real quick.
The same origin policy is the basic security
policy that browsers and user agents try to
get Web sites to comply to in the Web.
And the same origin policy basically says
that two objects can interact directly if
and only if they belong to the same origin.
An origin, which is taken from the URI of
those subjects by looking into the schema,
the host and the port of that URI.
Now, the good thing about talking and reasoning
about origins is that the most common security
vulnerabilities can be described in terms
of origins.
When untrusted content or script gains the
authority or runs in the context of a particular
origin, we talk about cross-site scripting.
When a possibly malicious origin gets the
network access privileges, the Web request
privileges of another origin, we talk about
cross-site request forgery.
And for some reason which I don't understand,
people really like to say cross-site scripting
with an X and cross-site request forgery with
a C. I will never get that.
Now, a lot of the features that I'm going
to talk about today can be very easily implemented
in an extensions manifest or a Chrome apps
manifest.
But after helping many teams at Google write
more secure apps and extensions, either for
Chrome or for Chrome OS, I notice that people
made the same mistakes over and over again
not because they didn't know what they had
to do, but because there's some tricky, like,
nuances that one has to know in order to make
CSP or sandbox iFrames work correctly.
So I wrote a very simple app, which I call
Manifest Lint.
Not very creative, but that's what I got.
It will highlight sections of the manifest
that are okay from a security perspective
and sections that might need help.
In this case I am feeding the actual manifest
of the Manifest Lint application to itself
and it's telling me that I'm not setting a
content security policy.
Now, I will go deeper into content security
policy in a couple of slides.
But first I want to show you what happens
when one develops an application and doesn't
really take into account security.
Now, I wrote this application in time to demo
it at I/O, and one could wonder what happens
if the application takes a manifest in that
text area and displays the highlighted manifest
on the other side.
Now, what happens if the application receives
a manifest that is not necessarily benign,
that is malicious or malformed?
Well, let's try that.
I'm going to switch video, and if I cannot
make this demo work after what Sergey did
on Wednesday, I'm going to feel really, really
bad.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Okay.
Awesome.
Now, the extension -- the app basically takes
a manifest and displays it highlighted on
the other side.
It also saves the manifests to local storage
so that I can bring them back and not have
to input them all the time.
Now, what happens if I input this manifest?
I hope -- yeah, font size is okay.
Which has a very weird description.
It's got HTML tags in its description and
image tag and JavaScript.
It's not looking good.
If I input this manifest into my extension,
nothing will happen, but maybe eventually
the user might go over a part of the manifest
and I hope it reads, but that's one of the
things that's stored in local storage.
Now, we don't expect just random input to
be able to read local storage of the application.
And in this case it's just manifest.
It's not really secret or private, but this
could be user's data, private data, email,
whatever, anything that's stored in the app
or the extensions origin is now available
just one confusion, one trick away from an
attacker.
I'm going to go back to the slides.
What's the problem?
That's the problem.
I'm using eval to parse JSON and I'm using
inner HTML to display the highlighted manifest.
Now, I'm not going to go very deep into what
the exploit does, but it's basically using
the fact that I'm using inner HTML to inject
script into the application that is triggered
when the user mouses over the image.
Now, since I'm -- since the use of inner HTML
basically allows me to inject any sort of
tag or script that I want, that's basically
giving a straight way for an attacker to get
malicious input into my application.
And this is where content security policy
comes in.
In a nutshell, content security policy is
a way for me, the application or extension
developer, to tell the browser, only allow
me, the application, to load resources or
script from this whitelist or trusted sources.
Now, it might be -- might sound kind of weird
since I'm telling the browser to restrict
what I'm -- what me, the application, is allowed
to do, but since we've seen in the demo that
it's very easy to hijack the behavior of an
application, it's a very powerful tool, CSP,
and it allows me to -- beforehand to say I
don't want to be able to load anything outside
of these trusted sources.
By doing this, by not allowing the application
to load script or resources from untrusted
sources, we prevent most cross-site scripting
attacks; however, in order to be able to tell
whether the script or the resource that we
are loading actually belongs in the whitelist
or not, we need to be able to tell where that
script comes from.
And the problem is that we are not always
able to do that if the script that we're loading
is included in-line, in the application.
There's no way for the browser to tell whether
inline script has been put there by the developer
or has been injected due to a bug in the application.
The only way in which CSP can fulfill its
purpose and actually block things that are
not in the whitelist is to ban all the uses
of inline script or features in JavaScript
that turn strings into code because you can
never be sure whether the inline script was
malicious or not or whether the string that's
been turned into code by eval is malicious
or not.
Now, how do we use it?
If you're writing Chrome app or in extension
it's really, really simple.
You just add one line to the manifest called,
very creatively, content security policy.
And a content security policy itself is just
a list of allowed sources for different types
of resources.
In this case what we're saying is that by
default the application is only allowed to
load resources from its own origin.
That's what the, quote, self quote, token
says.
Now in case of scripts we want to allow the
application to load scripts from its own origin,
the extension package, as well as the googleapis.com
site.
And in case of styles, CSP does include a
token called unsafe inline, also with quotes.
This can -- this can be used to turn off the
requirement for a script not to be inline;
however, if we use an unsafe inline token
in the script source line we're basically
defeating the purpose of CSP.
We are not gaining any advantage.
Styles are not the same thing in the sense
that they don't directly execute code.
And in most cases it's the trade-off between
not being able to use inline style and the
possible exposure to malicious CSS.
And buggy parsing CSS code in the browser
is really not that problematic.
The most important thing in this case is we
cannot load script from anywhere else but
those two sources.
Now, if I try to load this, my application,
with this new manifest, I'm not going to do
it in the computer because the text of a JavaScript
console is very hard to make bigger.
So that's exactly what Chrome prints if I
try to load my existing application with this
new manifest.
And it's basically saying what we expected
it to say.
If content security policy doesn't allow inline
script, then, of course, Chrome is refusing
to run inline script.
If content security policy doesn't allow in-line
event handling, which is basically the same
as in-line script, it's JavaScript code that's
included in-line in HTML.
And Chrome has complained about one more thing.
It complaining about the fact that I'm loading
jQuery or HTTP.
Now, in a regular Web site this wouldn't necessarily
be a problem since you're already loading
the Web site over HTTP.
The fact that you're loading script over HTTP,
it's really not that problematic.
However, if you're running on extensions,
extensions get more privileged access to the
browser compared to regular sites.
They have access to APIs.
The normal sites don't have access to.
If you're leading script over HTTP, you're
exposed to what we call mine-in-the-middle
attacks.
If you're using your extension at a Starbucks
hot spot, then any person sitting at that
Starbucks hot spot can intercept the loading
of that -- that script loading over HTTP,
change it and make you run malicious script
in the origin of your extension, which has
privileged access to the browser's API.
And as we've seen, from there to stealing
private data is just some code away.
Now, we need to change, of course, these few
things in order to make my teeny-tiny application
work with CSP.
That's basically what we're going to do.
I change the jQuery loading to load over HTTP,
which is a source that I have enabled in CSP.
And I'm going to -- I'm going to extract all
my JavaScript code into a .js file, which
is something I should have done in the beginning.
Best practices for Web development call for
separation of the structure of the document
in HTTP, the behavior in JavaScript and the
style in CSS.
This is the easy part.
I also have to get rid of inline event handling,
which I can very easily translate to native
JavaScript using a bit of jQuery magic.
I'm saying that the lint function is going
to be the handler of the link that I use to
tell my application to process the manifest.
And finally, I have to change my eval function
into JSON parse.
Now, I didn't use the fact that the application
was using eval to run my exploit.
I just used the fact that it was running HTML;
however, since the application was using eval
to parse JSON, instead of doing crazy things
with tasks, I could just send a JavaScript
statement as a manifest.
Now, that would have been slightly cheating
in my opinion because there needs to be at
least an impression of, well, this could have
seemed like a regular manifest in order for
the exploit chain to be somewhat credible.
If I'm just telling the user to paste something
that starts with alert as a manifest, then
I'm kind of cheating.
The good thing is that I'm not going to get
rid of inner HTML.
And now we'll see why.
I don't really need to get rid of inner HTML,
although it would be very good to do.
What happens if I try to do the same thing?
Just so you see that I'm not faking it, I'm
going to go back to the demo and I'm going
to try to load the same -- it happens.
We broke everything.
I'm going to use exactly the same manifest
in the safe version of the application that
loads with the content security policy that
you guys have seen.
If I try to do that, it will load, but if
I mouse over the little square, which have
the onload attribute, nothing happens.
And the console, which clearly you guys cannot
read that, but it says "Refuse to execute
event handler because of content security
policy."
So I'm protected, which is really cool.
It's the same thing that is on the slide,
my demo failure slide.
And the interesting thing is that the way
I see it, CSP allows the application or extension
developer to rely on the browser as a safety
net.
I'm pretty sure that I covered every single
base, I'm pretty sure that I tied every loose
end, but just in case I haven't, please, you
browser, make sure that I don't screw up.
This is what I'm talking about when I say
that application developers and browser developers
have to work together in order to protect
users.
The browser can make sure that your application
never uses unsafe script.
You guys have to use the feature that the
browser provides in order to allow the browser
to do this.
Now, people might say, "Well, that's a really,
really simple app.
It doesn't really do anything useful."
And you might very well be right.
So I want to move over to something that's
very dear to my heart, which is the Chrome
OS document viewer.
We applied these two security features to
the Chrome OS document viewer.
The Chrome OS document viewer allows Chrome
OS users to open a lot of different document
types, including Office files, online on their
Chrome OS devices directly from the Chrome
OS file manager.
Everything runs on the Web/Chrome platform
and it runs offline.
Now, when the developers of the development
viewer were working on the application, we
wanted to make sure that it was a safe application.
Opening Office documents, it's dangerous,
and we wanted to make sure that we could do
it in a safe way.
So the first thing the developers did was
apply a content security policy to this app
or extension.
In this case it's an app.
It doesn't really change that much from what
I did with my demo app, but it's interesting
that they are also using unsafe inline for
styles, and this makes a lot of sense because
if you're writing a document viewer you cannot
really predict what kinds of crazy document
formatting the author of those documents might
do.
So you need to create script -- sorry, styles
on the fly dynamically and load them inline.
Now, in this case, again, this is a matter
of it's a trade-off between the functionality
of the application, basic functionality of
the application, which is displaying the styles
that are included in the document I want to
view, and security, which is I'm not really
happy with loading inline CSS because it might
open me to be -- to injection for malicious
CSS, but we trust the CSS parser in Chrome.
If killing inline styles kills the purpose
of a document viewer, then we need to allow
it.
Security is always, most of the times, about
tradeoffs.
Another interesting thing is that I'm using
a couple more resource sources that I haven't
shown before, which are image source, which
of course governs which images can be loaded
by the application.
And I'm using blob URIs for images.
I going to come back to blob URIs.
I wanted to show it today so it stays in your
mind.
I'm going to come back to blob URIs.
I'm also using frame source.
Now content security policy includes more
types of sources.
There's a bunch of them.
I'm not going to go over them, but if you
type content security policy in Google it
takes you directly to the list of it.
Now we come probably the crucial part of the
talk.
Which is -- CSP is awesome, and it really
prevents cross-site scripting, but we haven't
seen that much adoption by the development
community.
So the only way we saw to make this really
happen was to force, to make a default CSP
policy apply by default when absent extensions
start using Manifest V2.
Now, if people here attended the talk on Wednesday
about Manifest V2, they probably have an idea
of what the schedule will look like for Manifest
V2.
I'm going to go over the schedule again, but
let's see exactly what exactly is forced by
Manifest V2 in terms of CSP.
The first line, script source self, object
source self, it's going to be the default,
unchangeable, "unloosenable".
CSP policy that's going to be used in all
(indiscernible) extensions that use Manifest
V2.
The reason for this is the same that I've
been talking about.
If -- if your upper extension loads inline
script, the browser cannot really tell whether
the script that is executing comes from a
trusted source or not.
The same thing happens with plug-ins.
If we cannot -- if you are loading a plug-in
over HTTP, and you run on public Wi-Fi, then
the plug-in that you are getting in your extension
does not necessarily look like the plug-in
that you thought you were getting.
It might have been changed in transit and
you can have no way of telling.
Both scripts and plug-ins run code in the
context of your extension.
If we cannot be sure that that code is trusted,
we cannot give that code the privileges that
the extension has.
So that's going to be the default.
However, in both cases, since we trust the
resources that we load over HTTPS, it's allowed
to include HTTPS sources both as script source
and as plug-in source.
You can load plug-ins and scripts over HTTPS
because it's very much guaranteed that the
scripts you're going to get is the script
that you actually want to get.
One more thing that you can do with CSP, which
is interesting, is that when you write Chrome
apps and extensions, you use host permissions
in order to govern which Web sites you can
inject content script into, but those same
permissions govern which hosts you can do
XHR requests to.
If you need to do XHR requests to a smaller
number of hosts than what you need to inject
the script into, you can further restrict
the hosts that you allow XHR requests to happen
against by using the connect source directly.
It might seem like not a very big deal, but
security is always about restricting privilege,
allowing things to have the least amount of
privilege possible so that if something goes
wrong, a compromise happens, the thing that
gets compromised will never be able to do
more than it was allowed to do in the beginning.
That's basically what we're trying to do with
CSP.
Now, this is basically how it's going to happen
with Manifest V2.
Chrome 21, which goes to stable in mid August,
it's going to block uploading new items to
the Chrome Web store that have Manifest V1.
With Chrome 23 that goes stable in early November,
even existing items that use Manifest Version
1 will not be able to be updated to new version.
And Chrome will stop packaging apps and extensions
that have Manifest V1.
Now in the beginning of 2013, we will remove
Manifest Version 1 items from search results,
so that they are very, very hard to find.
In the middle, beginning of Q2 of 2013, we
will completely remove all Manifest V1 items
from the Chrome Web store and eventually Chrome
will refuse to load them at all, whatsoever.
Now, it's almost a year from now, right, until
it doesn't really work anymore and the changes
are not really that big.
But the important thing is that this is the
only way that we can guarantee that your users
and the users of Chrome browser and the Chrome
extension and the Chrome platform don't get
compromised.
It's not necessarily because the application
developer is writing a malicious app, but
it's for the attacker to have a way in, you
just have to make one mistake.
For -- for the browser/app to win, you have
to -- you have to tie every single loose end,
so it's an uphill battle.
But we have some tools that help us win the
battle and we really need you guys to start
using these tools.
Now, the other good thing about CSP is that
it's also available or in fact it came up
as a solution for the regular drive-by Web.
It's currently supported in Firefox and Chrome
using the X content security policy in the
case of Firefox and the X WebKit CSP in Chrome.
Eventually, we hope this will be supported
in all browsers.
Now, there's some more issues that can come
up with CSP.
And I wanted to take a couple of minutes to
discuss them.
An issue that we have seen a lot with CSP
is how we talked about how it completely balanced
the use of eval because there's no way of
telling where that string that's being turned
into code comes from.
It's the same problem as within inline script.
The browser cannot be sure whether that script
is actually something the application developer
wrote and not something that a malicious user
wrote.
The problem is that many Web frameworks use
eval to do templating, for example, and if
we ban eval, then these things are not going
to work.
And in effect, there's a very cool starter
kit for ember.js that basically brings up
single-header (indiscernible) page using the
templating engine for ember.js which is handlebars.
Now if we use operate, very, very recently
content security policy similar to the one
that we used before, we are allowing loading
scripts over HTTPS, we are allowing inline
styles.
This is basically what the ember.js -- what
the ember.js index -- index HTML page looks
like.
It's true we are allowing the loading of that
script, everything else is loading from the
extensions on package.
But if we try to load it, we get a very, very,
very nasty error which basically says something
like code generation from scripts is disallowed
in this context.
It also points us to a source file and a line,
which basically says something like function
applies, something, something.
This is never going to work with a CSP policy
that actually does work as intended.
Now, there are two ways around this.
Way number one is for this frameworks to move
away from eval and other code generation functions.
Now, if you are actually writing the new package
apps and using Manifest Version 2 as we introduced
during I/O, there's another way of doing this,
which is using new attribute for manifest,
which is called sandbox.
Which I'm not going to go into specifically
in the version that's used in the manifest.
I'm going to cover it more generally, so that
it can be used also in the drive-by Web.
Before moving on to the next, to HTML5 sandbox
iFrames, a very big CSP don't, unsafe in-line
and unsafe eval or script source, completely
defeat the purpose of CSP.
Please don't do it.
If you need to do this, you probably are doing
something not wrong, but you are doing something
insecurely.
So please think again.
If you need to include this in your CSP policy,
then please, please, think about why you need
to do it.
Now, the good thing about CSP is that it provides
a very effectively live place for resources,
but it's not very granular.
It's either you are allowed to load this or
you're not.
What we would like to have is a way of maybe
running script in our application, but not
giving that script access to the extensions
or the applications origin.
It seems like there's nothing in between.
It's either not running at all or running
and giving complete access to user's data
and everything.
That's where HTML5 sandbox iFrames come from.
What we would like to do is to load that script,
execute it, but execute it in a different
origin than the actual application or extension
origins.
In fact, let's go even further.
We want to run it in an origin that's different
from any other origin out there.
We call those unique origins.
They are by definition different from any
other origin there is.
This is where the HTML5 iFrame sandbox attribute
comes in.
It allows loading resources, content or script
safely inside an iFrame that will get less
privilege than a regular iFrame.
And we can completely control which of these
privileges we give back and which ones we
keep away from the iFrame.
Now, it's as simple as using the sandbox attribute
on a regular iFrame.
If we do that, the code that we load inside
the iFrame will be restricted in this way.
It will live in a unique origin, so we won't
be able to access directly the application
of the extensions, DOM structure or script
or anything.
It actually -- if we don't do anything else,
it won't even be allowed to run scripts at
all.
Or submit forms.
Or navigate the top page.
Or load plug-ins.
Or create pop-ups.
Now, almost all of those things can be re-enabled
individually by giving arguments to the sandbox
attribute.
Except the loading of plug-ins, which so far
cannot be re-enabled.
Now, I said that we might want to use sandbox
iFrames to run script in a different origin.
So going back to the Chrome OS document viewer,
what the document viewer developers did was
run most of the JavaScript that displayed
the final document inside a sandbox iFrame.
And why did they do this?
Well, even though we might be pretty confident
about the JavaScript that we wrote, if there's
no need for that JavaScript to directly access
all of the private information that an application
such as a document viewer might have, why
give it that privilege?
If it doesn't need it?
If anything goes wrong with the JavaScript
that I wrote, which if I'm parsing a document,
as heavy as like a spreadsheet or something
like that, a lot of things can probably go
wrong.
So since that code doesn't need to access
every single file that I'm using in my document
viewer, let's just not give it access to that.
Let's just give it the one file that it needs
to display, so if anything goes wrong, it
cannot go and steal every single file that
I own and ship it away to somewhere.
So that's what the document viewer developers
did.
They kept most of the document viewer inside
of a sandbox iFrame, which was only allowed
to run script, and load pop-ups, but nothing
else, no forms, no plug-ins, nothing.
In this way, if anything goes wrong with that
code, the JavaScript will not be able to access
the extension or the apps origin where probably
the rest of the document, the user's documents
live.
And this is a very good thing.
Now, inside the sandboxed iFrame, there's
really not that much that changes.
This code is basically loading a lot of JavaScript
to do its job, to parse the document, and
display the document.
But it looks like every other single web app
that might be out there, except for one teeny
tiny detail, which comes from the fact that
that JavaScript code lives inside a unique
origin.
There's no way for the JavaScript code outside
of the Sandbox and the JavaScript code inside
the sandbox to talk directly.
They need to use some sort of inter-origin
API.
And the most recent inter-origin API that
they can use, of course, is postMessage.
It's explicitly designed to --
in a very JavaScript-y way, with asynchronous
message handling.
Now, this is what -- this is what -- what
message handling function might look for postMessage
in the drive-by Web.
The thing is that it is for security reasons,
it is good to check if the message that I
got over postMessage is being sent to me and
that's what the event origin tells me.
When you post a message using postMessage,
you say I'm intending this origin to be the
recipient.
When you get the message you say, hey, was
I the recipient?
Is event.origin the source that I expected?
Since they live in unique origins, their origin
is known, so we cannot really use that to
make sure that both sides of the postMessage
interaction are who they are.
But still is the only way we have to talk
to a sandboxed iFrame, so we are going to
have to use it anyways.
Inside the iFrame, we just need to get our
parent window and postMessage to that.
Outside the iFrame, we just need to actually
find the iFrame, get its content window and
postMessage to that.
Now, again, the objective of sandboxed iFrames
is to be able to use script that we might
not be comfortable with accessing our origin
but we might need to use it to set up a particular
aspect of our application.
In the case of the document viewer, the script
was displaying the final document to a user,
but it had no need to access every single
other document.
By running it in a unique origin, we guaranteed
that even if anything that -- anything that
went wrong, even if something that we didn't
think could go wrong actually did go wrong,
there was no way for that code, even if it
was compromised, to access any other document.
Which is a very good thing.
You don't want one malformed document that
you want it to see to steal every other single
document that you have.
A very -- other very important thing, more
don'ts.
Security is filled with don'ts.
If we can both restrict the limitation of
not running script and the limitation of running
in a unique origin, we can do it, we can do
them both at the same time.
However, if we do them both at the same time,
since the iFrame will be living in the same
origin as the enclosing page and JavaScript
will be allowed to run inside the iFrame,
there's nothing preventing that JavaScript
running inside the iFrame.
To get a reference to the actual iFrame, since
it's living in the same origin, and just take
the Sandbox out of it, out.
So either never use those two together, because
again as with unsafe inline and unsafe eval,
you are completing defeating the purpose of
the sandbox in the first place or make sure
that the script that you are including doesn't
have code that can do this.
You might not -- it's -- you might not be
sure that your script will not fail with a
malformed office document, but you can be
sure that it's not actually searching for
iFrames and removing sandbox attributes.
So sandbox iFrame don't.
Please don't do this because it defeats the
purpose and as many people say, a false sense
of security is even worse than being insecure.
So please don't do this.
Now, I mentioned at the beginning of the talk
that I wanted to cover some common issues
and pitfalls that came up when people tried
to do this in actual applications and I'm
going to go over those real quick.
We talked about most the CSP restrictions,
the really only really -- the only actual
pain point that we found was the use of eval
for templating (indiscernible) -- everything
else, even if it takes some work, is just
a matter of constructing script and constructing
event handling from HTML files.
It shouldn't be impossible.
We talked about how -- about how once we get
stuff into a different origin so that it doesn't
have access to the user's data, we need to
talk to it as if it were a different origin
because it actually is, so we need to use
inter-origin communication mechanisms such
as postMessage.
Now, I want to go over some weird interactions
that can happen when you use both CSP and
sandboxed iFrames at the same time, which
might not be evident when you start using
them, but it's good to know about them so
that you can know what to do when they actually
show up, if you decide to use that, which
you should.
This is what the final manifest for the Chrome
OS document viewer roughly looks like.
They managed to implement both sandbox iFrames
and CSP in document viewer app, which makes
it really secure.
I'm very happy opening a file in -- sorry
-- in the document viewer because it means
that the actual document that I'm viewing
has almost no access to anything else on my
system and that's something that's very cool
from a security standpoint, because if anything
goes wrong, there's nothing else that can
be accessed.
Nothing can be stolen.
Nothing can be affected, which is cool.
What happens, the key thing to realize is
that once we get the sandbox iFrame inside
a unique origin, when that iFrame tries to
load resources from the browser's perspective,
it will look as if those requests came from
outside the extension.
Because the iFrame is not going to be living
in the extensions origin.
Now, with manifest V1, you were allowed to
load everything you wanted from any origin.
In manifest V2, if an origin different from
the extensions or the apps origin tries to
load a resource from the app, the browser
will forbid that, and that's where Web access
resources come from.
If we want to load from the session package,
we need to list it in Web accessible resources.
And also, this also applies not only to the
main Web accessible resources line, it also
applies to CSP.
The things that we're loading inside the sandbox
iFrame, those requests will not look as if
they came from the extension or the app.
They will look as if they came from a different
origin.
So CSP will not allow those requests to go
forward by matching the "self" token in the
CSP line.
It will actually need to match that to a different
line that will have Chrome extension URI as
-- the Chrome extension URI as its URI.
Now, if you are running the new package apps
that come with the apps V2, that we introduced
for I/O, there's a slightly simpler way to
do this, which I'm not going to have time
to explain that talk.
But there was a talk on Wednesday that explained
it in more depth, and if anybody wants to
learn about that, please feel free to find
me after the talk.
But the core point to remember is that once
we manage to get stuff into the sandbox iFrame,
it's running inside and encouraging, then
it will have -- it will live in origin for
everything, even for resource loading, and
that might need to have us change some of
the CSP policies that we are using.
And again, we're seeing that I'm using -- or
the document viewer developers were URIs for
images and the reason that that happens is
that not only we kept script in a different
origin from our main application origin, we
also put it in a unique origin, which is slightly
different than just a different origin.
Unique origins cannot access any persistent
local storage.
No HTML5 APIs, no persistent local storage.
Now, imagine if you're obligation developer
and you had a great idea for a Chromized document
viewer, and you want to display documents
that might have images inside them.
These images are probably encoded inside the
documents in some way which we don't really
care about, but if you're not doing your processing,
or some of your processing inside the sandbox
iFrame, you need a way to get that information
inside the iFrame.
You might be extracting the images outside
the iFrame, or even better, in a different
iFrame.
And you need a way to provide that -- to get
that information inside the iFrame.
Now, the only way you have to actually communicate
with the code inside the iFrame is by using
post message.
So you might say, well, I'll have to take
the binary data from the image, turn it into
Base64, ship it over using post message, decode
it back to binary inside the iFrame.
That works.
Not very performant.
You have two Base64 to binary conversions
that you don't really need, and that's where
typed arrays come in.
JavaScript actually can deal perfectly well
with binary data.
You just create an array buffer, the size
you need in this case, 8 bytes, and then you
can cover that array buffer with different
what we call views which allow you to manipulate
that array buffer using different data types.
In this case we can manipulate it either as
an array of signed bytes or as an array of
signed 32 bit, but the best way about -- the
best thing array buffers is that they can
very easily be turned into objects that can
be loaded in the browser.
If the code outside the iFrame or inside a
different iFrame sends us an array buffer
over post message, we can easily turn it into
a blob, and then we can create a URL -- a
URL from that blob that will look something
like that.
We don't really care what it looks like.
We really care about the fact that it can
be used as a source for all sorts of tasks.
This is how the document viewer developers
manage to do the parsing of the documents
in one sandbox, and displaying in the document
in a different sandbox, passing binary data
back and forth using a very efficient mechanism
that doesn't need any encoding whatsoever.
Not only that, once you get the blob URI inside
the sandbox, you can use it all the times
you want.
It's a way of getting a URI pointing directly
to a chunk of bytes in the browser's memory.
This made possible to write a very secure
document viewer app and still keep all the
functionality that one would expect from a
document viewer.
Now, I mostly talked about JavaScript today.
Good news is that the Chrome platform also
includes a way of getting all these same security
guarantees for native code.
There were a lot of talks about (NaCl) Native
Client, in I/O, your -- you will probably
find them, the videos online after I/O ends.
(NaCl) allows you to get all the same guaranties
that we can give for JavaScript code running
inside a sandbox iFrame for native code, native
C or C++ code.
And the best thing is that the communication
with this sandbox code uses the same interface
that you can use to talk to JavaScript which
is a post message based API.
So you can get the same guaranties that you
can get with sandbox JavaScript, no access
to the application's origin, using the same
API.
Your JavaScript code can both talk to JavaScript
or to native code with the same security guaranties.
Now, take aways, and we'll move into questions.
Please, please, please, use CSP.
Please.
Let Chrome, the browser, be the safety net.
Just make some very small changes, move scripts
out of HTML, removing line handling -- inline
handling and stop worrying.
As long as you do stuff this way, the browser
will take care of not allowing malicious script
to go through.
This removes -- this blocks most cases of
cross-site scripting.
It does.
Because a browser can make sure that this
doesn't happen in only one place.
You have to make sure it doesn't happen in
every single way -- place you use inner HTML
or e-mail or server or everything.
Let us let the browser help the app make sure
that this doesn't happen.
And if you need to run script that you're
not comfortable with, you don't really want
it to be able to access the application or
the extension's origin, put it in a sandbox
iFrame.
That's what they are for.
It will run very happily, talk over post message,
but if anything goes wrong, it won't have
any other privilege.
It won't be able to access anything in the
extension of the app's origin.
That's a good thing.
Thank you for joining the session.
[ Applause ]
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: That's my e-mail.
My public Google+ account.
The slides are going to be posted.
I saw some people taking pictures of the slides.
Don't worry.
And, yeah, we're open for questions.
There's mics, yeah.
There's mics.
>>> Hey, so good talk.
My question is a bit of a tangent, though.
Have you guys seen very many actually malicious
Chrome Apps or extensions?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: We take out approximately
a dozen malicious extensions either per day
or per week from the Chrome store, yes.
>>> Okay.
What kind of attack patterns do they use in
general, if can you tell us?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: No.
It's probably better to contact press, yes.
>>> Okay.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Thanks.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: More questions?
No more questions?
Don't be shy.
>>> So what's wrong with attributes that have
JavaScript code in them, if they're just in
the static source of the page, as opposed
to being injected via inner HTML or the DOM
API?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: For the browser?
From the browser's perspective?
There's no difference.
So the browser -- the browser doesn't know
that the -- the on mouse-over script that
I added in the first demo is actually malicious.
I want the browser to be able to -- I would
like the browser to be able to block anything
that got injected by inner HTML as opposed
to stuff that got injected -- that got put
there statically in the page.
But there's -- in reality, there's no way
of telling the difference.
Once the DOM tree gets built, it's the same
thing.
Right?
The thing to include using inner HTML becomes
part of the DOM tree just as everything else
you included statically in the page.
So the browser cannot really tell the difference
between those two scripts.
We can -- if -- we can discuss it after.
>>> Okay.
Good idea.
>>> This question is more related to your
talk.
So you talk about using the X content security
policy header in the talk.
Recently the IATF deprecated the X prefix
for headers.
Do you know if Google is like trying to move
toward standardizing what that header is?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Eventually -- no.
Eventually we want to standardize.
I'm not exactly sure what the timeline is
for that, but there's definitely people you
can ask that if you want to.
I can tell who you can ask.
>>> Okay.
Sure.
Thanks.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Right there.
>>> I'm curious if you know the status of
CSP support in browsers other than Chrome.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: I don't.
>>> Kind of a continuation from that: What's
the status of this in the Android WebView?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: That's a very good
question that should be asked to Android developers.
Yeah.
>>> Hey, sorry, look, I think a big raisin
for not allowing inline JavaScript is because
you're basically assuming that it's all malicious
and you've got this policy to say if it's
not -- if any JavaScripts come from anywhere
else apart from where we said, malicious,
right, even if it isn't.
Is there much effort going into actually determining
whether JavaScript is malicious or not?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: You probably run very,
very quickly into, like, halting problem stuff,
right?
That's basically the case.
You cannot have a way of telling what source
code does that is 100% accurate so --
>>> Yeah.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: The only way to make
sure that -- it goes back to the same thing:
For an attacker to win, you just need one
bug, and in order for the rest of the people
to win, you need to tie every single loose
end, and going down a path that basically
has a lot of false positives and false negatives,
and very hard rules, it's just opening the
door for not one bug, but a million bugs,
so we want to cut the problem from the root,
and since it's perfectly okay, there's no
major differences except for evil, let's just
do what's safe for the user.
It's -- it's exactly the same.
It's just -- instead of having in HTML, do
it in JavaScript, instead of having it in
code, do it in our .js files, and we can guaranty
-- we can guaranty, we can say this is not
going to is happen, ever, ever, ever.
No exceptions.
>>> Well, unless your JavaScript on your server
gets compromised.
You can still be pulling it in from trusted
sources but it's been compromised anyway.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Well, exactly, but,
I mean, since -- it should -- would have to
be compromised either in the Web site that
is serving over HTTPS or in the actual expansion
package, which is a couple of orders of magnitude
higher than just sitting at a Starbucks WiFi
and running something.
>>> Which sort of gives rise to actually checking
whether the JavaScript itself is malicious.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Yes.
>>> So you kind of need to do it eventually.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: But again, tradeoff,
right?
>>> Yeah.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: We can make sure that
by -- there were some stats -- there was a
very interesting paper by a group -- a research
group at Berkeley that got published in the
beginning of 2012, by restricting inline JavaScript,
and restricting HTTPS or HTTP script loading,
you could completely eliminate 95% of all
the vulnerabilities in the top 100 extensions
in the Chrome Web store.
Now, the tradeoff for that is incredibly good.
It's just a couple of simple changes that
are still best practices for Web app development
get rid of 95% of the vulnerabilities.
>>> Yeah.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: It's like we need
to do this.
Guys, we need to do this.
Guys and girls, of course.
>>> Can we get -- sorry.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: That's okay.
>>> Can we get CSP to work in IE using Chrome
Frame, maybe?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: That's a very good
question to which I don't know the answer
with, but I'm going find the answer because
it is a very good question.
>>> I'm following you so post it.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: Okay.
I'll post it.
Good.
>>> Great, thanks.
>>> So you mentioned that because of blocks
eval, you know, blocks templating use cases,
I think I did catch -- so what's the alternative
do you do on something like client side templating?
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: So the alternative
-- two alternatives: Number one, try to make
templating people more like from evil.
Alternative number two, if you are writing
and one of the new package apps for the Chrome
platform, this doesn't work in the drive-by
Web, just for the Chrome platform, you are
able to say in the manifest using the sandbox
attribute -- in the manifest, not in the iFrame,
in the manifest, you are able to say this
document, when it's loaded inside an iFrame
or in a window, it should be put in something
very similar to a sandbox iFrame; however,
in this new sandbox document, you cannot remove
the same origin restriction.
You cannot say, hey, this has to live in the
same origin.
You cannot do that.
Since we don't allow that in the Chrome platform
version of sandbox iFrames, we can't allow
evil.
What we don't want to do is to say you can
run evil and you can also remove the same
origin restriction.
So if you do it through the manifest, you
can apply a different kind of security policy
to that document you loaded inside the sandbox
-- sandbox which can never ever live in the
same origin as your application.
If you want to go over the code, we can check
it out outside.
But if you search for sandbox in the new version
2 documentation, it's right there.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>Jorge Lucangeli Obes: I think we are good
to go.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]